there's never been a better time to be
involved in a technology company and
that is either one that makes technology
products
or has the main primary strategy be
rooted in technology it's never been a
better time because the opportunities
and all sectors of Technology are just
exploding the issue is it's never been
more challenging to be successful in
those environments so this program takes
a look at every functional area what may
have been termed in the old days general
management of a particular firm and then
layers on top of that the real key
themes of this decade which is things
like innovation globalization developing
alliances and truly becoming a leader of
your enterprise
we have a
as in faculty assistant so each faculty
member teaches three or four days
somewhere in that neighborhood of
sessions these take place in the morning
using an NBA style format of case
studies and some lectures and so on is
very highly interactive this is what
they call experiential learning so
everybody comes to the classroom and
contributes but these faculty are very
very special we've chosen them because
they are the best at that particular
subject that we can gain access to again
some of them or Stanford faculty may be
the majority but others come from all
over the world to join us so some you
might be surprised some of the the real
superstars although I think they're all
include the the two faculty members who
are teaching accounting and finance they
each have the leading textbook in the
area that are in 8th or 9th editions
they and they make finance and
accounting not only believe it or not
inspirational and exciting but that it
is absolutely geared to what is
necessary for a technology manager and
executive to know about right now the
leading themes in those areas so that is
some of the basics of you know business
obviously financing County but on the
other end spectrum we have a celebrated
author and professor from here at
Stanford robert sutton who's just
finished a book for example is you know
he's got a half a dozen books but this
one's good boss bad boss and i got to
get this right how to be the best and
learn from the worst so we not only have
tremendous learning going on on the
strategic aspects of running one of
these companies but also on how to
innovate to motivate and organized
after all this is still regarded as the
one of the primary centers of innovation
and technology in the world and when I
say this meaning Silicon Valley and
Stanford University so we take advantage
of that and in the way we execute the
program we spend mornings on lectures
but mostly case studies of both
successful and not so successful
scenarios of in all kinds of functional
areas of a technology company then we
use the afternoons for some special
activities having to do with either town
hall meetings with CEOs or working on an
innovation lab about what it means to
create a new enterprise whether within a
large organization or a brand new start
up and then evenings are spent in small
study groups with other executives not
necessarily from you know your own
company where I think that they turn out
to be maybe the most special part of the
day because of the intimacy involved
to be more than just a manager to be a
true leader in these enterprises at any
level and in any level is going to take
a special kind of person you can't just
understand a particular discipline or
technology you've got to have more
breath than that and leadership
creativity innovation and a basic
understanding of of the functional areas
of the business and we can do that and
we've proven we can do that with this
program for for high velocity high tech
con adventures and enterprises in 10
days
you